which fan favorite star can be spotted
in the background of the final episode
of The Walking Dead and how did they
score the Loki Cameo keep watching for
the details
after 11 seasons and over 170 episodes
the iconic zombie drama based on the
image comic series has reached the
Finish Line The Walking Dead capped
things off with a very eventful finale
that even brought back several fan
favorites including Rick Grimes and
Michonne there was even a small Cameo
from Chandler Riggs that many viewers
might have missed Riggs played the son
of Rick Grimes Carl Grimes for more than
100 episodes of the AMC series and
during that time the character had it
pretty rough losing one's childhood to a
post-apocalyptic Undead Nightmare is one
thing but losing a mother and then an
eye only adds to the punishment the poor
kid endured despite surviving all of
that he wasn't able to survive long
enough to make it to the show's final
entry out of all the character endings
on The Walking Dead Carl grime's death
was arguably one of the most outrageous
moments on the show and it didn't
necessarily go over great with fans the
character's final appearance was in
season 8 episode 9 and he's not been on
the show since okay
I don't want you to be sad after this
but the talented people in charge of the
show took advantage of an unexpected
opportunity to make sure the actor who
played the Legacy character entered the
frame one last time while Carl Grimes is
long gone Chandler Riggs managed to make
it into the final episode of The Walking
Dead toward the end of season 11 episode
24 there's a scene at the hilltop
Community where Daryl Dixon and Carol
Peltier are talking to Maggie ree about
what happens next in the background of
that ordeal there are several people
working and doing farming activities
including an individual standing way in
the back who looks suspiciously like a
two-eyed Carl Grimes that's because it
was Chandler Riggs playing a Hilltop
Farmer in the background of the series
finale while you might think this move
was a carefully calculated Endeavor
that's simply not the case it turns out
it was all by Chance the actor was
visiting the set and when they needed
extras he was chosen by director Greg
nicotero and Riggs didn't hesitate of
the opportunity to get back into the
walking dead he told Entertainment
Weekly they gave me a hoe and said the
part of the background for one of the
last shots and they just tossed me back
there and I just did some hoeing in the
ground in the background it was a lot of
fun it was just a quick thing before the
rest of the filming for the day so it
was pretty cool yeah Maggie hey
kataro also revealed two Entertainment
Weekly that Riggs didn't visit with the
makeup or wardrobe departments and that
he went to work in the clothes he was
already in saying I think we gave him a
hat to disguise him a little bit Norman
Reedus was thrilled to have his young
co-star on set and mentioned that he
tried to let the viewers in on the
secret saying they're trying to hide him
in the scene and I kept trying to move
my head like I'm looking at him to sort
of draw the audience's attention to hey
there's Chandler over there which I
don't think anybody really wanted me to
do but I thought it was funny so I kept
trying to do it it's not like we're
never gonna see each other again Maggie
herself Lauren Cohen was also excited to
have Riggs back telling Entertainment
Weekly Chandler is such an amazing guy
he's just really lovely it was a Class
Act for him to come that day while it
was brief and somewhat out of sight
having Carl Grimes in the mix is a fun
little Easter egg that fans will
appreciate but it does feel safe to
assume that Riggs series finale Cameo
could easily make the list of Walking
Dead cameos fans probably missed the
first time around